why you
L and you
change and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so as we continue our discussion on the
Civil War event we're largely going to
be sticking with the Civil War Frontline
series regarding the tie-ins of Civil
War issues number five six and seven and
the reason for this is because while the
other tiin give us a little bit of
information maybe some background
they're not nearly as important as these
other comics and for the most part they
don't really give us a whole lot in
terms of progressing the Civil War event
if anything they really kind of begin to
wind down and really kind of begin to uh
move towards this ultimate goal and for
the most part the ultimate goal is
something that we will see unfold but
the Civil War Frontline series is
particularly important going forward
until the series ends because as we will
see it really kind of evolves into this
who done it kind of mystery scenario and
then with Civil War Frontline issue
number 11 we ultimately really kind of
get this big reveal of why it was the
entire Civil War event happened in the
first place and what we see as we move
forward with Civil War Frontline issue
number six is that uh Jim who is a
cooworker of Ben yuck is really kind of
talking to Ben Yu and all all Jim really
does here is just kind of provide a
little bit of maybe comedy I guess he
really kind of talks about how he
himself is considering registering and
of course uh Ben yuck tells Jim that he
doesn't really have a secret identity
but but Jim really says that that sheld
doesn't really know that that sheld
doesn't really know that he's not a
superhero he could s just claimed to be
a superhero who's obscure and has no
real powers and this whole reason for
this is because the superheroes that are
registered with Shield they get a
pension they get a good salary and the
benefits of being a pro-registration
member of Shield is really just better
than the situation that Jim's in right
now again this isn't necessarily
something that we could take seriously
it's just kind of designed to give us a
little bit of humor what we also see is
that in the background Ben Yurick is
packing up his things and Ben Yurick is
really just kind of I guess maybe
vacating his office Jim doesn't
necessarily catch on to this right off
the bat but then he really kind of picks
up on it and asks benur if he's going
somewhere and Ben yuck replies by asking
him what was his first clue from here we
see that Ben yuck is leaving his office
and he runs into Robbie Robertson and
this is really kind of interesting we
see that Robbie Robertson ask Ben Yurick
where he's thinking and you know where
he's going and what he's doing and uh
benk really kind of replies that J Jonah
Jameson had fired him now Robbie
Robertson replies that this is just the
way J Jordan Jameson is it's just kind
of the way he is as a person and Ben
York says that after the first you know
15 years or so it was kind of funny but
it's not really funny anymore and he's
really kind of had enough of it in
addition we really kind of see Ben yuck
getting angry with Robert Robertson
because Ben yuck believes that this
whole uh this whole idea of the Green
Goblin is an important Story and there's
more going on with the Green Goblin that
meets the eye and that the Green Goblin
had threatened the family of Ben urick
and so Ben urick is not necessarily
going to take this as a very light thing
uh what we really kind of see here is
that Robbie Robertson ultimately kind of
strikes a deal with Ben urick and what
he says is that the Daily Bugle exists
to sell itself The Daily Bugle exists to
really kind of make money and that if
the Daily Bugle is not reporting the
story of the time which is the current
Civil War and registration issue then
The Daily Bugle will lose money but if
Ben yuck is able to provide any kind of
Truth and verifiable proof that the
Green Goblin story is something worth
reporting then Robbie Robertson will
back benur completely in the face of J
Jon and Jameson even if it means the two
of them could potentially be fired for
it from here we transition to Sally
Floyd and what we see is that Sally
Floyd is in some kind of undisclosed
location and the room that she is in
really kind of uh I guess appears to be
one of these rooms that's designed to uh
I guess maybe intimidate her but she's
not very intimidated by it in addition
an anonymous voice comes over the
intercom really kind of speaking speak
to her through one-way glass and there's
really kind of some Woody banter here we
of course see that this voice is asking
her questions like who is the individual
that tipped you off in the market in
Chinatown and so on and so forth and we
see that Sally Floyd is really just kind
of providing some witty banter she's
really kind of providing uh sarcastic
answers and she's not taking this very
seriously in addition what we also learn
is that the person who's asking her
these questions is Eric Marshall and of
course we had discussed how Eric
Marshall was one of the individuals or
the individual ual that had arrested her
in the first place from here we really
kind of see the two of them argue back
and forth and we see that Eric Marshall
is attempting to establish himself as
the authority figure but Sally Floyd's
really not having any of it and she
really kind of talks about how you know
she thought this was a free country but
it's really not the free country she she
thought it was when members of the press
can be arrested in violation of the
constitution in addition we really kind
of get a little bit of backstory here
between Eric Marshall and Sally Floyd
and we learned that of course Sally
Floyd had done a lot of reporting and
really kind of done a lot of
investigating on Eric Marshall and
learned that Eric Marshall was part of
the NSA and that Eric Marshall has a a
wife and three kids but we also kind of
learned that Eric Marshall had
apparently hit on her during the uh the
previous year's Christmas uh press Corp
conference and that Sally Floyd had
rejected his advances and so this
possibly indicates to us that the reason
why Eric Marshall is being so tough on
Sally Floyd is really kind of a way of
getting back at her because she refused
to accept his sexual advances but what
we also see here is that there is a
second person behind this one-way glass
and this person is Reed Richards and
Reed Richards tells Eric Marshall that
he is interested in offering Sally Floyd
a deal and we see that Eric Marshall
pairs these words by telling Sally Floyd
that they're interested in offering her
a deal from here we switch back to Ben
Yurick and we see that Ben Yu has been
assigned to cover the chemical plant
incident which was really kind of taking
place at the the same time that they
were reporting it and we see that Eric
Mars I'm sorry that Ben yuck is really
kind of embedded here now what it means
when a reporter is embedded as I
understand it is that the reporter is in
the midst of a conflict and is reporting
the conflict as it unfolds and the
purpose for this is for the American
people to really kind of get a
non-biased report of the conflict and
what happened Through The Eyes of the
reporter as opposed to getting a bias
report of what took place at the hands
of whichever government agency was kind
of at I guess involved in this incident
per se in addition we of course see this
conflict really kind of going on we see
the thing and we see Daredevil and and
uh Goliath and Ant-Man and all these
individuals fighting one another and for
the most part we really kind of see this
from the perspective of Ben yuck which
is really kind of interesting here
because again this gives us kind of this
understanding of the mindset the
Viewpoint of the normal civilian when we
see these major incidents take place
these major fights go on regarding this
Civil War super I'm sorry this
superhuman Civil War in addition of
course we see that Ben Yurick is
watching as Thor arrives and we see of
course that Thor kills Goliath and this
is really kind of a shock this is really
kind of uh an incredible thing for Ben
uich to witness and even he himself is
really kind of astounded to see that
he's really kind of caught unawares he
really doesn't believe that this is
what's happening that Thor would
legitimately kill a person and Thor
would really attack some of his his
closest personal friends and this is
really kind of an interesting comic book
thing this is really kind of fascinating
because what we see here is that the
relationship between various superheroes
the the relationship between some of the
found members of The Avengers and the
friendships that they have maintained
over the years isn't something that's
known only to them that everybody knows
about that everybody is aware that Thor
is one of the more prominent superheroes
in the Marvel Community everyone knows
that the friendships between Thor and
Goliath and Captain America and others
dates back decades and so it's really
kind of a a shock to see uh Thor
attacking basically his own friends and
such a ruthless and unquestionable way
from here we transitioned to seeing uh
Ben Yurick interviewing Tony Stark and
Ben yurk is really kind of interviewing
Tony Stark in two ways the first way is
of course he's asking questions about
what went on about why it is that Thor
had attacked the uh I guess Captain
America's team about why Thor had been
so ruthless and why Thor had killed
someone now Tony Stark's really kind of
elusive here he's really kind of dubious
in terms of his answers and really kind
of tells Ben urick that the only thing
he can say is that in due course Thor
will be completely exonerated but
doesn't really go into any more detail
than that in addition we see that um I
guess Ben yuck begins his other line of
questioning which involves the Green
Goblin and he really kind of ask Tony
Stark why it is that he's allying
himself with such dangerous and you know
I guess albeit criminally insane
individuals like the Green Goblin why he
would allow someone like the Green
Goblin to uh to be released and then we
see that Tony Stark really kind of
refuses to answer this question and
ultimately walks away and so from here
we switch to Robbie Baldwin and this is
really kind of an interesting comic
really kind of an interesting set of
circumstances we of course see that
Robbie Baldwin is uh I guess is is now
in the negative Zone area and is really
kind of I guess maybe writing a no to
his mother that we see and really kind
of talking to her about things that he
sees as he's being transported uh
throughout the Negative Zone and he
talks about how I guess in words of
sarcasm that this place is referred to
as Fantasy Island and that he can't
really understand why so many of these
people are homesick and of course again
this is a bit of sarcasm and what this
really kind of shows us is that these
conditions in the negative zone are very
harsh are very uh very cruel I guess
these individuals are not really kind of
receiving the necessary medical
treatment for for common illnesses or
for injuries they sustained over the
course of their apprehension that
instead in a lot of ways these
individuals are being made to live like
animals and what we see is that Robbie
Baldwin is taken to a location where he
meets with Reed Richards and this
meeting between Robbie Baldwin and Reed
Richards is really kind of interesting
here because we see of course that uh
Reed Richards is really kind of trying
to appeal to Robbie Baldwin trying to
tell Robbie Baldwin that they're
interested in offering him a deal where
he can again register himself and
effectively be free of incarceration
from the Negative Zone but Robbie
Baldwin doesn't really want to have
anything to do with this Robbie Baldwin
doesn't really want to have anything to
do with this entire uh superhuman
registration movement and doesn't want
to register uh as a member of the of
Shield forces in
addition we really kind of see him uh I
guess maybe um arguing you know further
with Reed Richards and and Reed Richards
goes as far as to say that Robbie Brown
has Robbie Robbie Wald has really kind
of changed that Robbie Baldwin is really
not the same kind of uh I guess
individual that would listen to the
other side that he's really so
entrenched in his ideologies that he
refuses to accept that anybody else
could possibly be right but then we see
that that Reed Richards really kind of
changes his tune that he really kind of
uh sings a different song and he tells
Robbie Baldwin that he will give Robbie
Baldwin the chance to speak in front of
Congress to tell Robbie Baldwin or to
tell Congress his side of the story to
tell Congress what went on and to really
kind of give the American people a
chance to see Robbie Baldwin for who he
is now Robbie Baldwin is initially
skeptical about this he's initially I
guess a little unsure about this but
ultimately he uh agrees and decides to
take the opportunity to speak before
Congress from here we transition to him
being transported with She-Hulk and
She-Hulk is really kind of talking about
his choice of attire is a terrible
decision and we see that Robbie Baldwin
has chosen to wear his old speedball
costume now the whole basis behind
Robbie Baldwin choosing to do this is
because he wants to show the American
people that he is still a superhero that
he is still a good guy and that the new
warriors were good people but She-Hulk
doesn't think this is a good idea and
the reason for this is because shehulk
thinks this is Robbie Baldwin's chance
to really kind of turn over a new Leaf
to one you I guess really tell his side
of the story but too to show people
there is more to him than the perception
that Society has of him that he is
inherently a good person that he was
acting as best he knew how and that the
perception of him as being some sort of
warmongering baby killer is not correct
but we see that Robbie Baldwin is
opposed to this idea in addition Robbie
Baldwin uh and She-Hulk are really kind
of exiting the uh the transit van
Transit bus and we see that security is
far less laxed than it's supposed to be
because of the fact that Robbie Baldwin
is in effect the most hated man in
America at the moment sec should be
multiple times what it is right now and
sheho calls attention to this saying
that there's supposed to be more
security than this and something just
doesn't seem right in addition as we see
an individual shouts Robbie Baldwin's
name and when Robbie Baldwin turns
around we see that this individual
shoots him at Point Blank Range from
here we again transition to Joe and what
we see is that Joe is now in his full
Atlantean form that he's no longer I
guess assuming the form of a normal
human being and he's really just kind of
floating in the water and really just
kind of talking in his normal Atlantean
language which of course is something
that we can't understand and then we see
that he exits the water and uh begins to
walk along up here now this is really
kind of uh an interesting scene because
what we also see is that Wonderman is
following him and what we also see is
that uh Wonderman is informing of course
Shield that he has tracked down Joe he
has located Joe and that he's really
kind of trying to figure out what to do
next his initial inclination is to act
directly is to get involved with Joe to
somehow kind of I guess attempt to
apprehend him or attempt to stop him but
we see that he's told not to by Shield
that he's simply told to just monitor
Joe to really just uh kind of uh keep
track on him to really just kind of
surveil him but to take no physical
action which of course Wonderman agrees
to do what we also see is that Joe is
heading towards a warehouse and we don't
really know what the purpose is at this
point in time but of course we see that
Wonderman is again continuing to follow
Joe and continue to monitoring him but
then we see that Wonderman lands on the
roof of the warehouse that Joe had
entered and when he looks inside he
calls for backup and what we learn is
that there's some kind of a delegation
of multiple atlantian forces meeting
here although at this time we don't
really know what their intention
[Music]
is
so as we continue with Civil War
Frontline issue number seven what we see
is that the Daily Bugle is in full
business mode the area is pretty chaotic
and everybody's really working on
something we see that uh individuals are
calling other individuals that they're
taking phone calls they're sending faxes
and so on and so forth and the place is
for the most part total pandemonium it's
really kind of what you would expect to
see in a very busy Newsroom we see that
Robbie Robertson is answering phone
calls he's putting various people on
hold and when Ben yuck calls he answers
him and he ask Ben yuck where he is and
Ben uich says that he is at the Capitol
building where he was assigned by Robbie
Robertson in order to uh cover the uh
meeting between speedball and Congress
and then we see that uh that Robbie
Robertson informs Ben Yurick that there
may be more to this story that Ben yuck
may be right about the story involving
the Green Goblin and that Robbie
Robertson ran some of Ben yur's concerns
past Tony Stark and Tony Stark clammed
up and due to the experience that Robbie
Robertson has the news industry that
this is really kind of an indication to
him that there really is something more
going on involving this Green Goblin
story we then see that uh Robbie
Robertson is really trying to figure out
where Ben Yurick is amongst all the
chaos and amidst all the uh the news
media at the Capitol building and Ben
yuck of course points himself out and
lets uh lets Robbie Robertson know where
he's at and then we see that speedball
and She-Hulk arrive we then of course
see from the perspective of Ben Yurick
that again this individual calls out the
name of speedball and that he shoots him
at Point Blank Range and we see that uh
that Ben urick really tells Robbie
Robertson that he was not the one that
shot him that he's not the one
responsible for this now from here we
switch to Sally Floyd and what we see
with Sally Floyd is that she is still
being held in an undisclosed location
and the situation is really kind of
unique here the way that this comic
panel really kind of unfolds the way
that it's given to us it really seems as
though she is crying but not necess
neily for any of the reasons that we
would expect she's not crying because
she's afraid of being held indefinitely
she's not crying because of the whole
Civil War um I guess superhuman
registration issue that's going on that
she may or may not be released on bail
she's crying because she's an alcoholic
and she needs some alcohol from here we
see that an individual named Congressman
Sykes enters her holding cell and
congressman syes is really kind of an
interesting character when it comes to
Marvel Comics Congressman Sykes really
kind of I guess Rose to prominence in
Marvel Comics after the events of House
of M and especially regarding his stance
on mutant registration and he's really
kind of I guess maybe expanded his
stance on mutant registration to the
Superhuman registration act and of
course he is pro- registration and he's
an individual that Sally Floyd has
really had quals with for quite some
time they've really bumped heads quite a
bit especially when it came to his
initial stance on mutant registration we
see that he hands her an envelope it
tells her not to open it until he tells
her when tells her to to actually I
guess open it and um he says that when
she does look at the contents that she
may very well rethink her position as
she's really kind of taken this stance
and really kind of made it uh I guess
outright that she doesn't like
Congressman Sykes at all from here we
see that the two of them kind of begin
to converse a little more and
Congressman Sykes says that he is very
similar to um to Sally Floyd that the
two of them are both Patriots the two of
them are both doing what they think is
best for the United States that they're
doing what they think is the right thing
to do Congressman Sy says that he
believes the registration Act is fair
and that it's the best and brightest
hope for uh the country to maintain the
element of superheroes with superheroes
being held responsible for their actions
rather than really kind of turning a
blind eye to what's perceived to be
vigilantes in costume in addition we see
that uh Congressman syy says he is going
to get Sally Floyd out of uh being held
that he is going to allow her to be
released and when she asks why he would
do this he says because he understands
that if there is any one thing that the
two of them hold to be the most valuable
thing it's the Constitution he talks
about how when he was younger he had
served three tours in Vietnam about how
he had been uh injured in the line of
duty how he was a prisoner of war and
that he and some of his friends some of
whom were killed had suffered and had
really kind of endured this fate in
order to ensure that people in the
United States were able to maintain M
their right to free speech that the
members of the press were able to
maintain their right to remain free from
prosecution as they attempted to report
information the best way they knew how
and that if there was any one thing that
the two of them agreed on that it's that
one concept that one aspect that they
hold the constitution in the highest
regard we see that Sally Floyd uh really
kind of uh believes this is a ruse and
she calls him out by claiming that this
is a trick we then see that Congressman
Sykes tells her she can open the
envelope and when she does the envelope
reads you will accuse me of trying to
trick you at which point he replies to
her and says who is more predictable me
as a congressman or you considering that
your answer was written on an envelope
before you even opened it up and at that
point we see that Sally Floyd really
kind of admits that she hates
Congressman Sykes no no more than she
does right now because he's absolutely
right about her stance and her
predictability and her outrage involving
the Superhuman registration movement now
what we also see is kind of a transition
to Osborne industry in New Jersey and we
see that Norman Osborne is meeting with
some individual that we don't we really
can't see we don't know who they are
this individual is really kind of
cloaked in Shadow and this individual is
providing Norman Osborne with a means to
suppress the Nanobots in his body and if
you recall when Tony Stark and Reed
Richards and Hank Pim began the process
of enlisting the aid of super villains
to help round up uh superheroes who
refuse to register they installed in
their bodies Nanobots and the Nanobots
would be a means of control if these
individuals choose chose to go Rogue or
if they chose to simply not follow the
instructions that were given to them
then the Nanobots would initiate an
electric shock R the person unconscious
and they would then be collected by
shield and this kind of substance is
being given to Norman Osborne is going
to override that it's going to take away
the ability for the Nanobots to
effectively do their job which will
really kind of allow him to go Rogue and
to do his own thing and to really kind
of operate outside of the parameters
that have been specified for him by
Shield
what we also see is that this individual
seems to be somebody on the inside that
neither Tony Stark or Reed Richards or
Hank Pim or any of those guys will be
prepared they'll be completely caught
unawares when they realize that the
person that's betraying them is a person
on the inside from here we again
transfer to or I guess transition to uh
the capital building to Robbie Baldwin
and this portion of the comic in my
opinion is one of the most well-written
aspects of the entire Civil War event
for the most part we don't get a whole
lot regarding speedball or Robbie
Baldwin in terms of him I guess having
any direct conversation what we really
kind of see here is that he's writing a
letter to his mom and the comic really
kind of unfolds in a way or this portion
of the comic really kind of unfolds in a
way where he's basically pouring his
innermost thoughts and feelings
regarding everything that's happened
since Stamford Connecticut he talks
about how um you know he had intended to
go before Congress and he intended to
lie he intended to tell them whatever it
was that he felt was the right thing to
do he intended to tell them something
that would assuage his guilty conscience
that would effectively absolve him of
any feelings of guilt that he had over
the the issue in Stanford Connecticut
and the reason for this is because he
really kind of regrets everything he
regrets the fact that he developed
superpowers he regrets the fact that he
was even you know part of the new
Warriors and he really kind of takes
time to reflect on this he really kind
of takes time to look at his past and to
really talk about how he misses his dog
and how he and his dog used to sit on a
particular position on the steps of
their stairs waiting for their dad to
come home he really kind of reflects
about how his mom never really gave him
a whole lot of attention and his dad
never really gave him a whole lot of
attention he really kind of talks about
how he looks back on the past when he
first developed his powers and became a
member of the new Warriors he talked
about how when they first encountered
terax when they first encountered Thor
uh when they really kind of got carried
away and and and when they were young
and they were Reckless and they were
really kind of foolhardy he talks about
how he wanted to start a reality TV show
and that some of the other individuals
didn't want to do it they were really
kind of hesitant to but he really kind
of pushed them and he really kind of
pushed them even further when they went
into the uh to the home of various super
villains one of which to house Nitro and
really kind of initiated the entire
Civil War movement and he talks about
how this reality TV show would be their
chance to really show what they were
capable of but that they ended up
blowing it instead and initiated this
entire event he really kind of um talks
about how if he said if he really kind
of admitted publicly that the new
warriors were at fault that it would
really kind of emotionally traumatize
him but while all this is going on while
all of this is taking place we see that
there are various kind of effects going
on in the ambulance we see some electric
shocks that are really kind of revving
up we see She-Hulk who's really kind of
trying to understand what it is that
Robbie Baldwin is saying and he really
kind of is appears to be slipping in and
out of Consciousness or as far as she
can tell he's slipping in and out of
Consciousness and he really is kind of
calling for his mom and really kind of
uh speaking his thoughts outward really
kind of uh I guess speaking out outside
of his own mind about what it is that
he's thinking and he says that he really
couldn't bring himself to say that the
new warriors were at fault that the new
Warriors had made a mistake because if
he did then he'd have to admit that all
of his friends are dead that all the new
Warriors and that all those kids and
that all those people that they're all
dead because of him and we really kind
of see that his body begins to kind of
convulse that his body really kind of
begins to uh jump up and down that it
really kind of begins to I guess maybe
go through what appears to be a seizure
and that all these electrical discharges
are taking place all around him and then
we really kind of see this bright flash
of light and we effectively see what
appears to be the uh I guess the
ambulance partially exploding and then
crashing into another vehicle now from
here we again pick up with the story of
Joe but what we see here is that
something has happened there's been some
kind of incident that has taken place
between the time that we uh I guess we
discussed Joe in Civil War Frontline
issue number six and now there's
apparently been some kind of attack that
has taken place that has resulted in the
death of all these atlantans and what
presumably is the death of Wonderman we
of course see that the detectives Donna
and Keith are investigating this entire
situation and they're really again
trying to figure out what's going on
they see that some of the weapons
belonging to these atlanteans are still
around the premises and of course they
uh have forensics lay down various
markers so they can really kind of
ensure that the crime scene is
maintained as best it can we of course
see that various individuals are
investigating the atlanteans themselves
and the question arises why were all
these atlantans meeting here in the
first place what what were they doing
here what was going on on here but then
of course we see that one of the inv one
of the uh I guess uh paramedics
discovers that Wonderman is still alive
they then begin to kind of uh address
him really kind of begin to um I guess
tentatively ask him questions despite
the fact that he may very well be
slipping out and out of Consciousness or
be in the last moments of his life and
then we get kind of a flashback to the
events that took place between Civil War
Front Line issue number six and issue
number seven and what we see is of
course that one man is continuing to
monitor the atlanteans inside this
Warehouse as he's on the roof and he
keeps calling for backup from uh from
shield and then he looks behind him and
sees that somebody is approaching and
asks Shield who this individual is and
shield says they haven't sent anyone yet
we then realize that this is the Green
Goblin Norman Osborne what we also see
is that Norman Osborne lays waste to the
entire warehouse and effectively kills
all these atlanteans now this is a very
very important thing and the reason why
is because we will see in later
instances of Civil War Frontline that
this
causes a huge ramification but that this
also ties in to the very ending of the
Civil War series and why the entire
Civil War series happened in the first
place what we also see is that Wonderman
is of course injured alongside the
atlantans that are killed and this
really kind of brings us back to when
the detectives first found him alongside
these dead atlantans in the first place
now the actions of Norman Osborne here
is something that I would like you to
again kind of pay attention because this
seems very uncharacteristic for the most
part while Norman Osborne can sometimes
be considered an insane individual even
when he's not the Green Goblin the Green
Goblin still has his own kind of agenda
he really kind of does his own thing and
it's very rare that we would ever see
the Green Goblin arbitrarily attack
atlanteans knowing what the
ramifications for this could possibly be
and so again this is something I would
like for you to keep in the back of your
head because this will become very
important later on from here we again
see that Keith and Donna are really kind
of discussing this situation they're
really kind of talking about what's
going on and Keith says this doesn't
really make any sense that this really
could not have been done by Norman
Osborne because Norman Osborne is
supposed to be in jail and so the
question is if Norman Osborne is not in
jail who let him out and if he is out
then why is it that he's killing
atlantans instead of going about his
normal business presumably of attempting
to attack Spider-Man and Keith really
kind of talks about how been on the fors
for about 20 years or so and that he's
afraid that this entire situation
everything that's going on here may turn
out to be a lot simpler than the
[Music]
truth
oh